we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
right-winger who loves the show take a
listen to this I just wanted to call
much you know I I lean more slightly
towards the right I'm a big fan of
Michael Savage and ben shapiro but i
really liked your commentary i've been
listening to you since I was fifteen
back in 2012 I just want to say you're
actually a really good host I do
disagree with you with a lot of things
that you say in most of your opinions
but you're a phenomenal host you got a
great radio you got a great personality
and keep up the good work David I don't
know if I should take this as a
compliment
that program is even appealing to some
right-wingers like fans of Michael
Savage and Ben Shapiro
or should I be worried that people who
listen to Michael Savage and ben shapiro
seriously are also finding something in
this show that they like i don't know
the answer but it is scaring me a little
bit we have a great bonus show planned
for you today we have more midterm
election updates yes they continue to
roll in we will talk about a major
philanthropic contribution that former
New York City Mayor Michael Bloomberg is
making it's very interesting we will
also talk about how Texas students are
soon going to be able to learn in public
schools that slavery played a central
role in the Civil War amazing that
that's something that they are only now
going to start learning what the hell is
going on in Texas all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show become a
member
become a patron both great ways to get
instant access to the bonus show I'll
speak to you then